good afternoon everyone my name is dr
miller and the scp we're going to be
looking at today
is scp
6333
delta level tier documentation access
object class
ketter special containment procedures
standard access protocols for example
level 4 and level 5 permissions do not
apply to
scp-6333 documentation
access to preliminary scp-630
documentation is provided to site
directors of facilities containing a
minimum of 100 officially designated scp
anomalies site directors may provide o5
approved abridged versions of
scp-6333 documentation to their
designated emergency successors as
desired access to comprehensive
documentation designated across five
access tiers may be requested by site
directors whose corresponding sites have
successfully maintained care of an
scp-6333-2 instance for at least three
consecutive decades
all
scp-6333-1 instances are to be carefully
cataloged and kept in high-priority
secure storage at sites designated by o5
council member consensus instances not
pertaining to hardwood tree species may
be requested for use when seeking
uncontained
scp-6333-1 instances permission from a
majority of o5 council members is
required prior to the planting of any
scp-6333-1
instances
scp-6333-2 containment chambers must be
equipped with air filtration systems
artificial sunlight lamps water
distillation pumps and gardening
supplies as appropriate manufactured
objects containing iron are not
permitted within
scp-6333-2 enclosures ideally
scp-6333-2 instances are to be contained
underground though exceptions may be
made for instances that exceed three
meters in height a team of at least 10
on-site researchers led by the site
director is to be assigned to each
site's scp-6333-2
instance
as of 2020 the 12 largest foundation
facilities worldwide each possess one
scp-6333-2 instance that has exceeded 50
years of age foundation sites seeking to
host ascp 63332 instance must petition
the o5 council with a detailed analysis
of containment history personal
psychological evaluations employee
turnover statistics and resource
allocation budgeting
due to the extreme scarcity of
scp-6333-1
and surviving
scp-6333-2 instances experimentation
involving
scp-6333 is to be kept in an absolute
minimum
description
scp-6333
refers to a set of plant-based anomalies
scp-6333-1
and scp-6333-2
scp-6333-1 are anomalous seeds primarily
of plant species commonly sold as indoor
house plants for hobbyists
scp-6333-1 instances are visually and
physically identical to non-anomalous
variants but will produce visible and
infrared light of increasing intensity
when in close proximity to other
scp-6333-1
and
scp-6333-2 instances
scp-6333-2 refers to plants grown from
scp-6333-1 instances the noted
variations between
scp-6333-2 instances and their
non-anomalous counterparts are as
follows
scp-6333-2 possess extremely heightened
longevity
scp-6333-2 grow into increasingly warped
and irregular forms as they age
eventually only vaguely resembling their
apparent species
scp-6333-2 do not produce seeds or
flowers
scp-6333-2 flourished best when kept in
the same vicinity as other anomalous
objects particularly living anomalous
entities the area of effect for this
attribute increases with the age of the
scp-6333-2 instance
scp-6333-2 exhibit immediate negative
reactions when artificial substances are
applied to any part of the plant
scp-6333-2 grant positive effects to
individuals that they recognize as
caretakers during certain stages of
cultivation see addendum 6333 1
addendum 6333 1 delta level
list of
scp-6333-2 instances and assigned sites
cataloged within the past 10 years
instance number scp 6333
2ae
assigned site site 64.
species euphorbia pulcherima poinsettia
anomaly variant gaukurena
recovery details
obtained from an apartment in oregon
united states initial caretaker was a
graphic designer who relied on freelance
commissions for income analysis of soil
composition indicated the presence of
partially decayed organic matter likely
composted by-products of the caretaker's
cooking
specific observations
scp-6333-2
responds well to application of various
types of fertilizers and nutrient mixes
on days when fertilizer was applied to
scp-6333-2ae
reports were noted if staff within the
site suddenly recovering from minor
ailments such as allergies fatigue and
aches
care modification history
while commercially produced fertilizers
are viable
scp-6333-2ae appears to respond best to
handmade or naturally produced nutrient
additives such as food waste compost
produced on-site and waste water from
freshwater aquariums provided the health
of
scp-6333-2ae is retained researchers
assigned to it will be transitioning
from using both commercial and handmade
fertilizers to using solely
non-commercial fertilizers
instance number scp-6333-2af
assigned site site 36
species gymnocalcium maihana witchy
grafted moon cacti
anomaly variant jayan mu
recovery details
obtained from a street food stand in
kolkata india the vendor was noted to
have no formal education but
demonstrated significant aptitude for
learning to speak new languages locals
familiar with the vendor reported
witnessing them frequently speak to
scp-6333-2af when practicing new words
in foreign languages
specific observations
following initial transport of the
instance to site 36 personnel noted that
it appeared discolored and did not
respond well to usual plant care one of
the researchers assigned to the entity
took the initiative to recite nursery
rhymes and tongue twisters in three
languages to scp-6333-2af
for 30 minutes following which the
instance's coloration returned to its
initial state the researcher has been
commended for their quick thinking
care modification history
tentatively assigned a designated team
of researchers is to rotate schedules
for reading aloud to
scp-6333-2af for three hours each day
reading material is to be submitted and
approved by the site director priority
is given to determining whether scp-6330
exhibits preferences for certain kinds
of listening material intelligence test
batteries have been requested to
determine if these reading sessions
affect the research team in any way
instance number scp-6333-28g
assigned site site-45
species drosentheum florabundum rosea
ice plant
anomaly variant yaks immix che recovery
details
obtained from the office space of a
national park near perth australia
animals of the park had previously been
targeted by poachers recent observations
indicated fewer poaching attempts due to
trespassers experiencing a sudden loss
of ability to navigate the park space
specific observations
scp-6333-28g
seems to attract more ambient flying
pests than other instances pests
approaching scp-6333-2ag
abruptly lose its sense of direction
upon entering within a 500 centimeter
radius of its container individuals
tasked with removal of pests upon
successful completion of the task report
that for the following few hours they
are able to automatically identify the
shortest and most efficient pathways to
various locations within the site
care modification history
current care plan is sufficient
suggestions raised regarding potential
d-class experimentation to determine if
disorientation effect can be manifested
upon humans in a controlled setting
instance number scp-6333-2
alpha
assigned site 19
species bachera aquatica money tree
anomaly variant yggdrasil
recovery details
successfully pruned from scp-6333-2c
and rooted blessed as viable by
serpent's hand clerics one of two
cuttings in the first recorded
successful human-initiated propagation
of scp-6333-2
specific observations
no immediate effects noted however
serpents and associates have
acknowledged scp-6333-2c
alpha generating what they believe to be
an immature way
such a gateway would allow for single
direction travel to the wonders library
should
scp-6333-2c alpha continue to mature in
good health
care modification history current care
plan is sufficient discussions underway
regarding additional protections should
a complete way entry manifest
instance number scp-6333-2c
beta
location unknown
species pachira aquatica money tree
anomaly variant igdrasil
recovery details
successfully pruned from scp-6330
and rooted blessed as viable by
serpent's hand clerics one of two
cuttings in the first recorded
successful human-initiated propagation
of scp-6333
specific observations
scp-6333-2c
beta has exhibited the most extensive
and immediate recorded route growth
requiring multiple container changes to
accommodate its increasingly large root
system as of the last recorded
behavioral log
scp-6333-2c beta has produced additional
anomalies specifically all handheld
pipettes used to dispense water in the
enclosure now repel loose particulate
matter dirt dust etc and if left atop
freshly turned earth will cause
seedlings to sprout from beneath the
pipette and grow in a linear trail
towards scp-6333-2c
beta
care modification history
per a non-unanimous o5 majority vote to
avoid further containment breaches and
to better ascertain the health of
scp-6333-2c beta the instance has been
released to serpent's hand custody
records will become available from
serpent's hand caregivers when the
instance is settled in its new habitat
addendum 6333 2 delta level
the first
scp-6333-1 instances came into
foundation possession in february of
1979 when a conference of ambassadors
was called between the foundation and
various tentatively allied groups of
interest the serpent's hand provided
each convoy with three
scp-6333-1 instances after ascertaining
each group's ability to cultivate rather
than exploit the eventual scp-6333-2
entity the foundation was one of the few
groups informed of the exact mechanics
of the seeking effect
scp-6333-1 instances possess
it is currently unknown how many
scp-6333
instances remain outside of foundation
guardianship based on current consensus
resources will remain devoted to the
care and protection of current
scp-6333 entities rather than attempting
to seize the instances in the custody of
antagonistic groups of interest
should
scp-6333-2 instances be determined
capable of manifesting autonomous
anomalous entities a reconnaissance team
is to be formed to collect information
on the progression of other groups
scp-6333-2
instances if necessary the foundation
will attempt to convene a second
conference
it has been proposed that allowing
multiple groups of interest to continue
cultivating scp-6333
regardless of intent will result solely
in positive consequences for all groups
regardless of existing alliances
whether this is truly the case remains
to be determined
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zolfax 99
ian j allsup
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim l ashmuy
talk of villagers
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
african submarine vore
amir saban
seventy
kristoff kozak zlazak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
pure osmium
sciodio demnatus
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
drew peacock
eric corbidge
longinus
james saba
and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you